so we're here at e3 2019 and you are
here to talk about doom eternal yes I
saw do a couple too and it's you know
more doom well what do you like about do
but ratchet it up quite a bit there's a
lot more I feel like emphasis on
controlling the battlefield as you're
fighting it's more of like thinking
about who you're gonna kill and how
you're gonna kill them in order to keep
yourself alive as you're fighting
through these like waves of enemies and
stuff yeah talking about these demons I
believe they said that they're going to
double the number of enemies threat game
did you get to experience any of that or
anything like memorable scanning out
anyway yeah you know there's these big
arena fights a lot like what's in do but
much more full lots more variety of
enemies it feels like yeah so yeah yeah
like you've got you know your big huge
guys the wreckin inspire guys coming at
you with their Gatling guns guys yeah
anything you've got all the little dudes
around so you're figuring out like who
the priority targets and how you're
gonna take them out and what you're
gonna do about it and like what your
armor counter has and whatever health
and ammo counts are and all this is like
a constant sort of puzzle solving aspect
of the fight short so how challenging
was this like did you find yourself sort
of having to like relearn how to play
Doom at all or was it wasn't super
familiar it kicks off pretty quick it
was you know it was tough to get sort of
back into it but then it all kind of
clicked and especially when you're
ratcheting through different guns you're
like okay I'm out of you know Rockets
I'm out of chain gun but I've got lots
of - chainsaw you know once you get
rolling with it it came back pretty
quick no I guess when 2016 doom came out
like it was it was such an impact one
because it was a great game but -
because we hadn't really had anything
quite like that in a while I think it
also caught people by surprise cuz their
e3 presentations leading up to that I
don't know that everyone really saw in
those presentations what we actually got
at the end do you feel that this game is
going to have a similar impact
considering that it is in many ways just
a continuation or you know an expansion
of the ideas that we're in 2016 - right
um I think it'll probably hit pretty
hard because of what it's doing is
grabbing all those great ideas from doom
and finding new ways to make them
interesting right so like the game feels
much more vertical and deal with 2016
was a pretty vertical
right but now you've got your your
double jump and you've got this cool
grapple hook on your shotgun right which
you know in most cases just like what
Nayla guy but if you pair that with
jumping you pair it with bouncing off
pads and like getting up on extra levels
and stuff now you're thinking about how
I'm gonna get across the level to the
other guys I have to deal with before I
get killed on the way and so it's a
whole nother aspect of that that whole
line of thinking and yeah it just feels
like it everything feels smoother and a
little more punchy I guess yeah so yeah
I mean I guess unfortunately Tony you
didn't get a chance to play the the
multiplayer I guess it's PvP mode for
lack of a better way to describe it
we're essentially use the player get to
possess a demon and go fight against
someone who's going through their own
campaign right is that right yeah I
didn't get to play that unfortunately I
just got it what felt like a snippet of
you know what a standard level would be
like but it did have some interesting
news or new ish feeling stuff like
they've been talking a lot about
incidental combat between arenas and
there are a few instances of that where
you're you know you're it's not just
running through hallway to get to your
next fight it's thinking about ok what's
ahead of you and how you're gonna again
stock up get ready yeah for those big
fights and then another portion of the
the demo was a lot of like platforming
we jumped into this weird Canon that
sort of we turned us into a shell and
like shot us a Mars yeah it was a whole
like thing and then you're there just
like floating chunks of rock because I
guess the planet is crumbling or
something and so you're dealing with
jumping around on all our using your
grappling hook to get between those can
use the grapple hook on animaux right
also it's a very good combat focused God
trying to idea guys yet so that's what
we know about doom eternal at e3 2019
for more games at the show stay tuned to
games 5
you